hey what do you want I just want to let
you know that you're not alone we're
here for you I'm here for you
have you made any sales today oh you are
angry I like that like I got divorced
I'd probably be pretty angry too
first I'd have to get married but then
I'd get divorce you need to get back on
the man horse right cuz I think I know a
certain horse man that might want to
take you out for a trot
are you seriously hitting on me right
now hey no I'm not that was my horse
impression saying no I just want to know
what kind of dudes are you into these I
want a hot as balls male model are you
online gating I need to hire a model for
the company website you dummy is that
right salt